i can't put my finger on when i read
your book um i i believe if i'm not
mistaken i was i was at an airport at a
layover and i had about five hours
between flights and i just picked up
your book um at the
airport bookstore
and it was a bit of an eye-opener you
know because
my entire life
you know as a young man they always told
you you know go to school get good
grades take accounting courses learn
business blah blah blah
and along comes his book called rich dad
poor dad where there's one dad that does
it wrong and one dad that does it right
and the guy that does it wrong happens
to be your dad and the guy that did it
right was you know the character that
you created
in the series how did you how did you
come up with that notion of the rich dad
poor dad concept
well it's a true story
when i was um nine years old i went to
uh we moved i grew up in hilo hawaii
which is
the farthest city south 19.5 latitude
north latitude
and i moved from one part of town to
another part of town my father was the
head of education poor dad
and there were two schools side by side
one right across the street from each
other
and one school was for rich white kids
another school was union school which
was for immigrant kids
and so you know hawaii is a plantation
state so kids came from all over the
world you know asia china portugal
philippines
so the kids i should have been with were
at union school you for unionized and
riverside school was for rich white kids
or primarily the rich kids who are
primarily chinese
so chinese and whites
and i'm going to this little small
school across the street from where i
should be going
and the first thing i noticed they all
had nice bikes and i had this old piece
of five five dollar bike
i wanted to know at that point at night
i said you know how come some people are
rich and how come some people are poor
you know you're nine years old you want
to know so i asked my school teacher her
name was mrs baptiste
she could have played the wicked witch
of the north but anyway
he trashes me for
you know the love of money is the root
of all evil and all that stuff here we
go that's where it started
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute you know
and i said i
it may be evil to you but it's not evil
to me and so i go to my rich i go to my
poor dad and ask him the same question i
said how come we don't learn about money
at school
and to me it was a normal question and
he said well we don't teach money at
school and i said that's strange
so he says but if you want to learn
about money talk to your best friend's
father
and that was mike's father and he was
chinese he never went to school
and he went he never went to school
because his father died
and he had to take over the family store
at 13.
so he got on-the-job training if you
know what i mean
and
so i started i
so i asked my poor dad the academic
i said um
what's the difference he says well one
guy's an entrepreneur and i'm an
employee and so i get more confused as a
kid well what's the difference
and it says an entrepreneur must know
about money and employees don't
and i just thought that was very very
strange
but that's where the story started so i
think i'll work for my rich dad for free
in his head restaurants and hotels and
all this stuff
and he would teach me the reasons you
work for free because if i pay you
you'll start programming yourself to
think like an employee
and as entrepreneurs don't work for
money and that's getting more confused
and uh so finally
he's teaching me playing monopoly you
know i said so i work for free
and he spends about an hour a week
playing monopoly with his his son and me
and so finally i asked him i said why
are we playing monopoly
and he said
well because one of the greatest there's
millions of ways jesus million ways you
can go to a financial heaven there's
different ways
but one of the best ways is on monopoly
and i said what's this what's the
formula
he said four greenhouses 1031 texts
before exchange into a red hotel
i went what
he says it's right in front of you and
this is a lesson for everybody wealth is
always right in front of you
sometimes you just can't see it
so i was 19 i got my 18 i go to school
in new york i got nominations in naval
academy into berkshire academy i took
march marine academy
and when i came back from new york in
i was
you know what they call a fourth class
in a plebe
richter had bought the red hotel so he
went from greenhouses to red hotel so
i'm observing him work working his
business plan
and that red hotel today is a hyatt
regency on waikiki beach
okay
now
i thought i read somewhere that that
rich dad was a fictional character but
you said that that he was actually your
friend's dad right
yeah well you got careful who you talk
to because you know like
when rich dad poor dad came out i got
trashed
yeah new york times took me over the
calls
all the academic elite took me over the
kohl's because they all want to believe
that their college degree makes them
superman or superwoman right
and you didn't have one so
yeah you know i'm glad i went to college
but i didn't my my college degree isn't
uh naval architecture and ocean
transportation i've never used any of it
right right what kind of student were
you in like elementary school in high
school were you good like an a student
or just a
no you know that thing that is they
always say asians you know all the
asians are battling out in harvard
because there's too many asians getting
into harvard well i didn't help that
curve at all that was the bottom bottom
half okay you know you got to study i
didn't study i played i still play
monopoly
but you know it's not a bad thing you
know i wasn't i wasn't a great student
either i mean i was i was probably a c
average student in fact that you know
i've told the story before it's probably
been a while since i mentioned it but i
um my grade 8 teacher couldn't couldn't
handle me in the classroom i can't
remember what her problem was but i
ended up getting a desk in the vice
principal's office for a week and pretty
much for the entire week he's lecturing
me about you know if you study and you
do everything right one day you can be
sitting at my desk and you know you'll
be a vice principal of a public school
like me and i i don't know he was
getting paid at the time you know
nowhere near as much as what i make now
obviously right but
um
you know it's always funny when you get
those academics there's um
there's a guy that i met at a conference
that once said um don't let school get
in the way of your education i guess
that's something that you resonate with
yeah yep yep yeah
and then the funny thing is is that
because i know you like cars right oh
yeah so all my friends we we
mclarens were ferraris
and um we all have different
our grade point average on our license
plate so mine was c plus and my other
friend is c minus
yeah i've got some friends with plates
like that i got a friend that's got one
that says no degree
yeah um you know stuff like that but
yeah it's or no wife you know
yeah whatever whatever seems to work
you